when I asked Robertson can you bring the
syllabus from your book that says why
must you waste and evil
[Applause]
mm this isn't the offense so how's it
doing well as you guys know on my
channel I don't like to be too serious
all the time I like to bring a few jokes
even there and one thing I've been seen
in the park last because one of that I
bother me I usually go to is that when
it comes to us and the certain way that
we follow from like follow the world
around us from that and the way of the
cellar we have a lot of enemies we state
besides being a Muslim yeah because now
in the park you can see for example the
chem it's the blackest realized the
Christians the atheist they oh this is
patent they always come together against
Muslims always I'm gonna save all of
them I seen all of them I'm concerned
individuals in the pub who followed that
this fake Christianity whatever it may
be they always come to me what I've seen
this a lot and I've done a video about
this with muhammediye on OCC Dawa which
I will link at the end you can watch it
there yeah ask him how many job why is
this happening now this what exactly
happened after my debate with Tony
Robinson when I went up to him and I
exposed him and I confronted him to give
me a simple versus wrote a whole book
about Islam why Muslims to Islam but not
a single verse was brought forth is she
oh yeah now with the shirt
in general we do not believe that is
filling this yeah our problem is with
those who curse our Mother Angelica and
her and the Sahaba Amalia rather and I
didn't accept that's how important but
in general shows our own our sheer
balances out there to think that I'm
doing a personal attack against them
it's not that this is the sheer specific
share individual yeah okay that they
will take the side of certain Christians
atheists against you just because I
think it just shows how much someone
hates you that they have to go to this
level yeah but look what happens
yeah when they come and chase me harass
me a little aggressively it look what
happens and how and this just wanted to
share with you guys also just to keep
you guys updated in Charlotte then the
points and debate that I had that I
didn't go to much easier for example the
matter of high bar the perfect marriage
Sasha and her
apostasy we're gonna do reaction videos
with mom at her job and you start at nan
Russia and maybe she'll vomit as well
we're gonna cover this in detail for our
non-muslim
and Muslim so you can get grasp of full
understanding and look out for my videos
this week covering all those topics in
detail and also do check out my video
we're comfortable Robin says which is
gonna be linked at the end take care
good bye that